well it's great to be at the G20 Summit
here in Indonesia I think in the wake of
covid and Russia's War many countries
around the world are facing similar
economic challenges to us at home so it
will be good to discuss with other
leaders how we can fix the global
economy of course I'm also going to take
this opportunity to condemn Russia's
illegal hostile activity in Ukraine and
lastly I'm looking forward to sitting
down and building some strong
relationships with other leaders like
President Biden from America and the
prime ministers of Japan Australia and
India and maybe China it may be
president yes president XI is here and
like all the other leaders hopefully
I'll have a chance to talk to him too
I'm prime minister you said you will
call out Putin and call out the war in
Ukraine but president XI and PM Modi
where will they well I I'm going to use
this opportunity to unequivocally
condemn Russia's hostile and illegal war
in Ukraine and I know that other allies
will as well because it's right that we
highlight what is going on and hold
Russia to account for that and I won't
shy away from doing that you accept that
there will be no condemnation of this
war from the G20 and communicable there
you cannot get everyone to agree can you
the G20 is a very different Forum to the
G7 for example you know the G7 is a
group of like-minded liberal democracies
with similar values the G20 we have to
acknowledge is is a different grouping
but that doesn't mean that we shouldn't
be engaged in it we shouldn't make our
voices heard and constructively work
with people where we can to make a
difference for people at home as well
and you saw that recently when it came
to migration the ability to talk to
other countries can have benefits for
people at home and that's what I'm here
to to deliver well let's just go on to
people at home because the economy you
said last night you have to follow
through on tax Rises and spending cuts
later this week because your government
and this is to quote you has to meet the
expectations of international markets
and put public finances onto a
sustainable footage have you had to make
harder choices because of Liz trials I
think actually being here reminds
everyone that the challenges that we
face at home are Global in nature that
global economy is recovering from covert
and dealing with the aftershocks so
specific but also but also Russians war
in Ukraine is a primary driver for
Energy prices and inflation and that's
why the IMF has made the point that
actually almost a third of the world's
economy either is or will be in
recession so we're not alone in facing
these challenges I know other leaders
here will be talking about how do we
make sure that global economy is
resilient to high inflation Rising
interest rates and what the chancellor
is rightly set out is that we will need
to take some difficult decisions but
that's in order to limit the increase in
mortgage rates to get inflation down
those are the right things to do but we
will have fairness and compassion at the
heart of all of those decisions I
promise my question was you do
acknowledge that your predecessor made
this harder because of the choices they
made in the mini budget well actually
well I I on the steps of Downing Street
I said that mistakes had been made are
part of the reason that I became prime
minister was to address them and what
we've seen now is that stability has
returned to the United Kingdom but
that's because the expectation is that
the government will make those difficult
but necessary decisions to ensure that
we can get a grip of inflation reduce it
for people with the cost of living also
limit the increase in mortgage rates but
I really want people to be reassured
that what the chancer is working on is
that all the decisions we make will have
fairness and compassion at their heart
and I'm confident on Thursday people can
see that that's what we've strive to do
some compassion a hint that you'll keep
the trick or triple lock I'm not going
to bother asking you because I know you
won't answer that question but what I
will ask you is this you're saying that
you have to make hard economic choices
to have sustainability of public
finances but the Fallout for all of ours
is that they're going to be hard choices
for our own finances aren't there for
everyone around the country it's going
to be tough the chancellor has set that
out very recently indeed and I think the
right thing though is to be honest with
the country and we shouldn't pretend
that there aren't some difficult choices
ahead because that's what's required to
ensure that in the long term we can do
the things that will benefit people's
finances because if inflation gets out
of control that's not going to help
anyone if if interest rates keep
spiraling that's not going to help
anyone but I'm confident that what the
government would deliver on Thursday
will be fair it will be compassionate it
will deal with the challenges we face
and put us on a path to recovery for the
future I made just final questions
couple of questions on the UK French
deal that was announced today you're
making some progress but numbers making
the crossing over the channel now at a
record high of over 40 000 people this
year can you guarantee as prime minister
that you will reduce this number next
year
I I said last week that gripping illegal
migration was an absolute priority for
me it's a thing I've spent most of my
time on outside of the economy since I
became prime minister and I've also said
though it's not an easy problem that you
can solve with a single policy overnight
and that's why we need to work on lots
of different things I put prioritized
working with the French at the heart of
that because without their cooperation
it's hard for us to solve this problem I
spoke to president macron about it when
I first spoke to him I further met with
him and we went over in more detail and
I'm pleased that as a result of that
dialogue we now have a new deal with the
French which is going to mean 40 more
patrols happening in France and for the
first time are officials embedded in
their operations that is going to make a
difference and hopefully people can see
that that's the fruits of the work that
I've been talking about but there's more
to come and people should know that my
question was can you guarantee that the
numbers will fall next year no I'm
confident that we can get the numbers
down but I also want to be honest with
people that it isn't a single thing that
will magically solve this we can't do it
overnight but people should be
absolutely reassured that this is a top
priority for me I'm gripping it and as
I've said in in the time that I've been
prime minister you're already starting
to see some progress with this deal with
the French but that's just the start
there's lots more that we need to do